grab yourself a Choco rocket because if
it were up to me this entire video would
be about Bobby Bobby
yes season two of Sweet Tooth is out and
with it a whole slew of new Mysteries
surrounding Gus the hybrids and an
Arctic Expedition that's sure to change
everything we know in this video we'll
be uncovering the show's Biggest
Mysteries theories for season 3 and
where the heck did all those other
hybrids go at the end of season one
they're dead They're All Dead just a
heads up this is a non-comic spoiler
video and make sure to like And
subscribe or else my parents will ship
me off to Alaska the final episode
begins on a diorama of Evergreen General
Abbott's proposed City free from the
sick a virus that plagued Humanity nine
years ago resulting in what is called
the Great crumble to make this dream a
reality he's called upon three Warlords
Voss Dutch and Zhang using the promise
of a cure to Wrangle them to his cause
but little does Abbott know that the
Cure does not work and this is where we
find Dr Aditya Singh he knows that this
cure does not work and in frustration
destroys this fake Town not only has he
lost the Cure but also his wife Ronnie
he's been focusing on creating a cure he
never took into account what his wife
wanted even if there was a cure I
don't want it she leaves behind a statue
of Ganesh a gift given to her by Addie
years ago which symbolized having a
piece of Home Addie has now lost that
home he's lost everything his wife The
Cure in his own sense of morality having
experimented on hybrids in his quest for
the Cure so he locks himself in a room
full of this purple plant a plant that
grows around those infected with the
sick and he does so with the intention
of killing himself but as fate would
have it there's much more in store for
the good doctor while drifting off Addie
hallucinates now this is interesting
because the show states that the plant
only causes hallucinations to hybrids
but it's never explained how it has a
similar effect on him his Hallucination
is so powerful that he sleeps through
the entire battle between Abbott's men
and the animal Army but what's most
interesting is how Addie's hallucination
links up to where season three is headed
in episode 1 we see that Gus's mother
birdie is somewhere in Alaska her
journey has led her on a mission to the
farthest ends of the Earth with the
hopes of getting answers or possibly
even a cure for the sick you see birdie
worked on Project Midnight Sun a
research project funded by Fort Smith's
eccentric president Jillian Washington
Washington became obsessed with the
story of her great-grandfather Dr James
Thacker who embarked on an Arctic quest
in search of the Fountain of Youth you
see he and his family suffer from a rare
genetic muscular degenerative condition
so when he heard there was a tribe of
people living in the Arctic who never
got sick and lived over a hundred he
sought them out in the hopes of finding
a cure for this disease fast forward
over a hundred years later in his great
granddaughter Jillian has picked up the
mantle using her vast well to make her
own expeditions to the Arctic tundra
there she collected microbes from the
ice tens of thousands of years old and
it was birdie who infused these microbes
in chicken eggs in the hopes of creating
a viable culture now two of these
cultures developed one would become Gus
or genetic unit series 1 and the other
became the sick which A desperate
Jillian Washington injects into herself
becoming patient zero this is part of
the reason why many humans think the
hybrids cause the sick the two
originated at the same time and place
but technically it was a human who
created all this as long as there's no
cure birdie knows Gus won't be safe this
is why she makes the decision to travel
to Alaska rather than Yellowstone to be
with Puba and Gus episode 1 offers some
valuable clues that connect to the
hallucinations both Addie and Gus have
later on in the season here we see
birdie using a drawing to uncover the
whereabouts of Dr James thacker's ship
we aren't sure who drew this picture
since it's implied Dr Thacker died on
the ship we'll see this giant purple
flower spreading out of a skeleton
holding Dr thacker's Journal so it's
heavily implied that this is Dr Thacker
himself and that the sick was here over
a hundred years before we originally
thought but since the Arctic was so
remote it never ever had the chance to
spread now I tried to decipher as much
of thacker's Journal as I could but most
of it was blurry and out of view and
nothing I did see was too revelatory
however there are two drawings that are
quite interesting the first is the
drawing of a figure and a cave I don't
think this is Gus as I don't see any
antlers but if I were to place a bet
it's Addy while hallucinating we see him
carrying Gus toward a similar looking
cave and check out these spats of blood
which just might be those two markings
in the drawing this cave is seen in yet
another hallucination when Gus recovers
from his wound there he dreams of his
mother in this cave who sits in front of
a fire fueled by antlers this all hints
at some sort of hybrid living here in
the Arctic that would mean that Gus is
not the first of his kind these Hooves
snow Prince seen by birdie Addie and Gus
hint that some sort of hooved creature
is likely aiding them we also get this
deer skull figure in Gus's dream could
this be the same person or thing out in
the Arctic there's also a deer drawn in
the journal and a deer symbol on the map
of Alaska which we'll see later on when
Addie awakens from his sleep finding
that his life has been spared and Gus's
antler on the ground he takes it as a
sign that his journey is not at an end
he must find Gus and travel to Alaska to
continue his research but there are two
other parties on their way to Alaska too
there's Gus Becky Jeff and Wendy who
found a promising lead when Becky found
that one of Gus's books aptly named
Bambi about a deer losing his mother was
written on top of Fort Smith research
paper circled in red is the Alaskan
Outpost of agbagniagvik try saying that
five times fast it's where Fort Smith
conducted project Midnight's son named
because for part of the year the Sun
never sets there's also Mrs Zhang the
leader of the biggest warlord faction
introduced thus far after she recovered
an audio recording from Addie's lab it's
safe to say she'll be on her way to
Alaska too and we see her chopping up
pieces of meat to these unseen creatures
to be determined if they're animals or
hybrids many of our characters also go
through their own personal Journeys as
the season progresses we have Jeb
struggling to come to terms with a
guilty-faced once being a hybrid catcher
a job he took so he could find his way
to his wife and son only to figure out
they'd been killed in Amy Gus and the
hybrids Jeff has found a new reason to
live and a sense of redemption there's
also Becky who joined the last men to
get to Gus and along the way found her
long-lost sister Wendy who was taken
from her when hybrids were rounded up
she found Birdie's cassette tape which
Gus will later listen to which explains
why she never went looking for him but
of all the characters who had an arc I
thought it was General Abbott's brother
Johnny who had the most tragic ending of
all Johnny had grown up with his brother
after Abbott killed their abusive father
Abbott was this protector-like character
while Johnny was always seen as the weak
one Johnny struggles to balance what is
right with being alongside his ruthless
brother he doesn't want to hurt the
hybrids but at the same same time feels
loyal to his bro this all culminates in
the finale where Johnny holds his
brother at gunpoint even firing the
handgun which Abbott secretly removed
the bullets Johnny finally found the
strength to stand up to his brother and
is killed for it while Abbott descends
on puba's Cottage the rest of the
hybrids are escorted to the Andersons
who we met in season one it's unclear
whether the hybrid kids will make a
return in season 3 as Gus Jep Becky and
Wendy head out on their own adventure
perhaps one of the weirdest elements of
the finale is the Buffalo Stampede when
Abbott has guests on the brink of death
Gus screams out in pain and seemingly
calls on the power of these migrating
Buffalo or bison I can never really tell
the two apart it's so strange that Jeff
even says did you do that this hints
that Gus may have the ability to commune
with other animals I mean if he doesn't
then this is simply bad writing and an
example of deus ex machina when some
outside force comes in and saves the day
with Abbott gone and Gus set up on a new
adventure that team tricks off to Alaska
and fun little detail here you can see
that part of his antler that was cut off
has started to regrow remember that
Wendy told him his will come back
stronger and I thought that was a nice
touch to cap off the season but what did
you think of Suite 2 season 2. I want to
hear your thoughts and theories in the
comments below thanks for watching
everybody please make sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
the story YT until next time remember
foreign